[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
Bienvenidos en Primera Plana un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana volvemos a poner el foco
aquí en Francia con la reforma de las
pensiones ya promulgada y aprobada pero
con los sindicatos que quieren volver a
la calle el 1 de Mayo una crisis que no
sabemos bien si está cerrada cuando se
cumple el primer año del segundo mandato
de macron en el poder para ello nos
acompañan en este estudio tres invitados
les presento ya Matías arraez periodista
en la cadena publique sena bienvenido
Buenos días Carlos Sandra jabalera
periodista independiente bienvenida
corresponsal del diario el periódico
bienvenido Buenos días la reforma
aprobada pero la crisis no cerrada
macron y ahora que hoy es nuestro asunto
en Primera Plana
coincidiendo con la fecha para los
trabajadores del 1 de Mayo los
sindicatos franceses quieren realizar
una movilización histórica de Récord
para demostrar que su pulso contra
macron continúa Aunque la reforma y esté
aprobada y promulgada entre en vigor el
1 de septiembre el presidente en su
último discurso manifestó que quiere
volver a encontrar el diálogo social y
avanzar en su agenda pero no lo va a
tener nada fácil un año justo después de
haber sido reelegido macron tiene el
desafío de ampliar su mayoría o bien
llegar o incluso a una coalición con la
derecha moderada para gobernar Francia y
todo ello con muchos retos sobre encima
de la mesa algunos urgentes a corto
plazo como la sequía que afecta a
Francia y se va a agudizar en el verano
boreal repasemos las portadas de prensa
a diario un quinquenio a relanzar
liberación con una de sus portadas tan
simbólicas con un montaje de macrón
marchando sobre una cacerola símbolo de
las protestas estos días bajo el titular
un año tras su reelección huele a
quemado lemond dice en esta otra portada
que el presidente se encuentra aislado
frente a los resentimientos de la
población un año después de ser elegido
Bueno un año después Matías pero parece
que ha pasado un eternidad
macron Cómo se relanza un quinquenio con
este malestar social en la calle el
presidente lo tiene muy difícil la
crisis Social es muy profunda y una
fractura que es cada vez más grande y lo
vemos con el rechazo a la reforma que no
para yo creo que al nivel social salvo
quitar la reforma va a tener que dejar
pasar mucho tiempo lo que le queda hacer
serían las palancas políticas que
podrían ser disolver la asamblea
nacional pero ya dicen los sondeos que
él no tendría ninguna ventaja Por
hacerlo Pues la otra opción que le queda
sería cambiar a la primera ministra a
ver con un miembro de la mayoría un
miembro de los republica que sería la
derecha para para poder relanzarse y
poder también ofrecer otras perspectivas
políticas Sandra que teclas puede pulsar
macron para relanzar su el diálogo abrir
diálogo es lo que está haciendo está
visitando un montón de lugares de toda
Francia
viendo a los yendo a los ayuntamientos
encontrándose con el pueblo intentado
reanudar un diálogo que se ha roto con
esta con esta reforma Enrique Bueno yo
creo que
sería básicamente cambiar las políticas
los finales del Gran elemento más
significativo de la situación actual no
que a pesar de de tres meses de
movilizaciones
multitudinarias no según los datos del
Ministerio del interior francés las más
importantes que ha habido en Francia en
este siglo XXI a pesar de ello Emmanuel
macron no quiere cambiar nada de sus
políticas en el fútbol lo que dijo en su
discurso del 17 de abril y esta misma
semana la primera ministra Elizabeth
cuando presentó la agenda legislativa
para los próximos meses donde
presentaron medidas que hubieran sido
prácticamente las mismas en el caso en
que no hubiera habido protestas hubiera
habido protestas poco importantes la
intersindical todo por perdido y el 1 de
Mayo pretende una movilización histórica
en las calles de Francia con la reforma
ya aprobada Y promulgada recordemos esta
crisis les pregunto a los tres estalla
descontada estalla cerrada está cerrada
en falso Matías la incógnita resulta en
cómo va a ser la movilización del lunes
vamos a ver si si los sindicatos estarán
aquí se los partidos políticos también
hay otras fechas que da el 3 de mayo
para saber si el consejo constitucional
va a aprobar o no el referéndum de
iniciativa compartida y también a
Mitades de mayo tenemos esa propuesta de
ley del grupo liot en la asamblea
nacional que sería el grupo
independiente para quitar esa reforma de
la de las pensiones en verdad no se sabe
muy bien toca saber cómo cómo los
partidos políticos van a esas
fuerzas que que nacieron de las de las
manifestaciones y cómo lo pueden
transcribir en
iniciativas políticas uno de septiembre
Último cartucho para los sindicatos
Enrique hay que verlo así sí Bueno en
cierta forma es un poco el epílogo no de
este pulso por las por las pensiones yo
luego lo que creo que es interesante de
este 1 de Mayo es un poco que en cierta
forma si la movilización es importante
no alrededor de un millón de personas en
toda Francia sería la manera de
certificar esta victoria de los
sindicatos de Cara a la opinión pública
en cierta forma una victoria moral es
decir aunque no ha conseguido su
objetivo que era evitar la aplicación de
esta reforma de las pensiones sí que es
verdad que los sindicatos al menos en
estos momentos dan la sensación de haber
salido bastante reforzados de Cara a la
opinión pública con un aumento del
número de afiliados pero sobre todo un
poco la que se han mejorado la relación
que hay entre los sindicatos y sobre
todo esta Unión de todos los sindicatos
y como nos ven los franceses bueno es
una parte importante de la ciudadanía
francesa que lo que he dicho Uno de
septiembre 1 de Mayo me refiero siempre
al 1 de Mayo claro la duda a partir de
ahí sandres si macron va a sistema de
estar social le continuar persiguiendo
durante todo este quinquenio hasta 2027
o si hay un punto final y pasamos a otra
cosa a ver es posible pero la verdad es
que ya no es una cuestión del retiro de
la Reforma de Hot Head es más una
cuestión
constitucional democrático O sea la
gente está hablando está saliendo a las
calles el 1 de Mayo se va a reunir
millones de personas para decir estamos
en contra escucharnos a es como el
último canto del signo no para bueno es
una destrucción francesa para decir cómo
es como su última oportunidad para poder
Mostrar que están en contra Y es que lo
que se pone a prueba es una cuestión
democrática o sea pasar una ley a
fuerzas con un 49.3 con un 47.1 con
todas las estratagemas que han hecho
legales pero que han hecho para poder
pasar una ley a fuerza sin escuchar al
pueblo esto es democrático o sea es
estar en la cuestión y cómo apaciguar
una populación unos ciudadanos que ya no
creen en la política que no creen en la
gente que le dirigen del lado de la
protesta la violencia ya parece que la
hemos dejado atrás y ha dejado paso a un
objeto la cacerola y todos sus
simbolismo muy desmarcado de la
violencia lo hemos estado viendo estos
días en todos los desplazamientos de
macron que también me parece muy
interesante comentar no que no sé si
macron durante esta crisis está
demasiado al margen y ahora se ha
lanzado sobre terreno qué les inspiran
estas caceroladas y esta nueva posición
de macron recorriendo Francia es una
imagen muy fuerte o sea las imágenes que
nos llegan de los desplazamientos de
Mahone es nunca visto aquí en Francia
está hasta Josué cuando estaba en el
punto más bajo de su quinquenio en la
opinión pública que estaba alrededor de
16% no tenía ese rechazo como lo tiene
Manuel obviamente también vemos las las
normas de seguridad que permiten
rechazar a los manifestantes y que poco
a poco permiten pues no volver a ver
imágenes pero lo que pasa es que esta
estrategia de ir al contacto esta
estrategia de estar a una distancia de
bofetada que es una expresión suya no le
está saliendo muy bien no le está
saliendo muy bien Por lo tanto no
haberlo hecho hubiera sido un error
tremendo tremendo voy a hacer un poco de
abogado del porque ese rechazo
visceral que causa macron cuando se
queda aislado en el Elíseo es que está
aislado es que no sale Y cuando sale
También muy mal porque como valoramos
esto
que en Francia ahora mismo hay como una
especie de bueno ha sido una especie de
trimestre antimacron de todo el mundo
está en contra de macron y se lo critica
por todos lados yo lo que es cierto que
lo que está haciendo actualmente
recuerda bastante lo que hizo después de
los chalecos amarillos no cuando dices
especie de Gran debate que en parte fue
una especie también de campaña
encubierta para para las europeas que
entonces le funcionó ahora no que se
repita porque dos veces la misma
estrategia no siempre suele funcionar y
luego es cierto que también en este caso
que parece hecho un poco de manera más
improvisada no que en el fondo lo que se
muestra es que al contrario de lo que
dijo macron no a finales de marzo donde
te dejo una entrevista en donde él
asumía la impopularidad al final un
presidente si es muy impopular Tampoco
puede gobernar o esto le priva de mucha
iniciativa política porque es verdad que
a nivel de popularidad también con lo
que está jugando Emmanuel macron en
estos momentos que es que aunque su
popularidad ha trabajado mucho aún
parece que están unos niveles donde aún
conserva una parte de su electorado el
núcleo duro de su electorado aún lo ha
conservado No que al final la gran
pregunta es qué pasaría si su
popularidad pasara del 24% actual a un
15%, que cayera bajo mínimos Entonces sí
que se vería obligado a cambiar de línea
política que es lo que no quiere hacer
de momento un núcleo que permanece y
luego veremos quién capitaliza del otro
lado todo este episodio recordemos que
en el Horizonte francés hay por delante
citas de vitrina el mundial de rugby a
partir del otoño la reapertura de notre
dame y sobre todo las olimpiadas los
Juegos Olímpicos de París cuenta macron
con estas citas para relanzar su
quinquenio Sandra
purpurinante cuanto menos unas
olimpiadas no son Sí sí Bueno es
recaudar también mucha fama y lo está
haciendo Ya haciendo visitas de estado a
China
viajando Bueno un poco por todo el mundo
es una forma de también Mostrar que es
un es un presidente presente presente ya
no solo representa
Francia representa también Europa
Entonces está haciendo Ya esta este
trabajo no de brillar no Entonces cuando
para Francia estas fechas de Juegos
Olímpicos que llegan del mundial de Ruby
y demás que de hecho el día muy curioso
el día del resultado del Consejo
constitucional también decidió hacer un
evento de respecto al aniversario de
cuando
es una forma también de poner purpurina
o de poner un diálogo aparte de
solamente que no sea siempre fijado en
el tema del egot
a corto plazo el presidente ha dado 100
días al gobierno de Elizabeth Board Para
calmar los ánimos y relanzar su proyecto
político y esta semana la propia voz
definió sus grandes líneas políticas que
margen le queda la primera ministra
Matías muy poca muy poca en verdad los
100 días es una referencia
políticamente son los 100 días de
Napoleón que se acabaron se acabaron Fue
una gran Victoria para Francia
recordémoslos pero pero realmente pues
las leyes que que anunció el otro día de
Elizabeth se conocían todas la la ley
laboral que va a incluirlo el contrato
indefinido o sea todas las normas que
cayeron con la reforma de las pensiones
la ley de la industria verde otra para
transcribir el acuerdo para el reparto
riqueza no hay nada nuevo realmente lo
que aprendimos el otro día del discurso
de Elizabeth Von es que no se va a hacer
una ley de inmigración
por esta situación en la que se
encuentra de que no tener mayoría al
gobierno No sí entonces ahí vemos que
ahí está está el callejón sin salida
para su política y y van a tener que
encontrar otras palancas porque si no
vamos a pasar cuatro años de Simple
gestión como como lo vimos en los
últimos años de Jack vamos una etapa de
pura gestión y de poco debate Enrique es
posible al mismo tiempo es en contra al
menos al menos el fantasma que Manuel
macron rechaza en cualquier caso es la
idea del presidente inmóvil como
comentaba Matías de Aunque es cierto que
en general los segundos mandatos en
Francia suelen ser bastante suelen ser
bastante complicados básicamente porque
en Francia todo el mundo piensa en las
próximas presidenciales que son en 2027
que para cualquier otro país por ejemplo
para para calendario electoral español
2027 parece lejísimos Pero en cambio en
Francia todo el mundo está pensando así
y el mismo Manuel macron es consciente
de ello y sabe que en el fondo un
segundo mandato al final casi su mandato
de 2 años que que a partir de 2025 ya
empezará la guerra de sucesión y los
posibles aspirantes a sucederle y
empezarán a tener mucha más luz
mediática y en parte capacidad de
influencia política el mismo presidente
de la república pues vamos a hablar de
eso también del final del macronismo
Pero va a ser a vuelta de pausa quien en
Primera Plana hasta ahora
todas las semanas tenemos una cita para
hablar de mujeres en ellas hoy hablamos
de nuestra diversidad nuestros logros y
nuestras luchas constantes aquí
entrevistamos a las que generan el
cambio en el mundo y les contamos sus
historias
[Música]
el día es hoy en France 24 y France 24
punto com
[Música]
France 24 es más que nunca una ventana
abierta al mundo
libertad
[Música]
vimos en Primera Plana esta semana
analizando la crisis social que vive
Francia intentando analizar si se ha
acabado si se ha cerrado en falso justo
cuando se cumple un año del segundo
mandato de Manuel macron cuando ha
llovido desde desde aquella religión y
en realidad solo ha pasado un año y pese
a todo a macron se le podrá reprochar
muchas cosas no sé si estarán de acuerdo
Matías arra de Sandra jabalera y Enric
bonet Pero ha reformado cosa que se le
echaba en cara a otros como shirak y que
macron podrá defender en su legado
enfrentarse a la impopularidad les
pregunto puede traer con La Atalaya del
tiempo el efecto contrario para macron
Matías es posible es posible y sobre
todo Él tiene que pensar en Quién va a
ser su sucesor Quién va a llegar eres
muy importante para él tiene un ego muy
importante que cuenta para ser político
y creo que está en su mente saber quién
va a llegar al escalón del iliseé en el
2027 esa impopularidad puede dejar una
brecha muy grande Entre él entre el
poder No solo él sino el poder y la
política y los franceses y de ahí qué
hacemos Esto me lleva a preguntarles si
creen que el macroismo sostenible en el
tiempo durará tanto como lo haga su
protagonista Sandra
No sabría decirte O sea no imaginabamos
[Risas]
imaginarnos que iba a presentarse para
una segunda elección y se lo hizo un mes
Antes nos lo anunció de repente O sea
que esto sería una hipótesis pero parece
complicado que haya un movimiento
simplemente de sucesión No simplemente
tantas veces hemos echado en cara macron
que sea tan personalista su movimiento
que ahora parece muy complicado
simplemente que sea quizá la duda es si
de ese especie de hipercentro de ese
movimiento se puede se puede canalizar
hacia hacia alguien hacia una persona
que salga de ahí Es evidente que cuando
un movimiento está tan personalizado
cuando caes a ese líder no esa persona
eso eso lo debilita luego es cierto que
en Francia que básicamente es un país
que está dividido en tres bloques no el
bloque de la derecha radical o la
ultraderecha que se bloquea el pen el
bloque de la izquierda donde es de
Mónica a la izquierda radical de The
Melany y luego macronista y en estos
tres bloques en el fondo también están
muy localizados No sí que al final lo
que es interesante de este ciclo
electoral es que en estos tres bloques
una pieza probablemente dos que es
macron Y seguramente me lanchón no se
pueden volver a presentar que eso es un
poco también la gran incógnita no estos
próximos años en Francia de que de que
habrá un vacío de personalidades que
tendrán seguro que no
se sabe por poder pero básicamente tiene
70 años
tendría 75 y por eso se especula que
tampoco viendo lo que estamos viendo
estos días en Estados Unidos
analizamos lo que hay enfrente les
pregunto por esos grandes personajes de
la política francesa y quién está
capitalizando todo este episodio todo
esta crisis social les pregunto
directamente Matías le pen es la gran
beneficiada de esta crisis social que
vive Francia sí claramente hemos visto
en estos últimos años que la política
del Silencio Paga y paga muy bien pero
estamos muy lejos todavía del 2027 y
esos sondeos sobre porque lo que sacaron
esos días es sondeos con los candidatos
del 2022 que muchos no van a poder
volver a presentarse ya veremos cuando
Habrá más campaña de momento está
hablando el descontento y veremos qué
pasará cuando llegarán los programas
cuando tocará hablar de política
económica de inmigración y de muchos más
programas le pen gran beneficiada
está frotando las manos porque como
sabemos crisis el movimiento
nacionalista
va a haber problemas para poder
restablecer alimentos básicos
la inflación va a aumentar
lo pensá está ahora frotándose las manos
porque la sensación nacionalista aumenta
también
ella de hecho hicimos una pregunta bueno
Y usted qué opina de la situación de que
se haya pasado la ley de Ya dijo si
queréis una respuesta en 2027 como
queriendo aplazando es votarme yo
quitaré esta ley porque es verdad que no
tienes esa relación tampoco con la calle
como la puede tener la izquierda metidas
sí es cierto que todavía no tenemos los
programas y que tocará evaluarla sobre
su programa donde sí va a beneficiarse
es que con este descontento va a subir
la extensión y con la abstención quienes
suben los extremos siempre
junto a hay una pregunta que está ahí
que si le perno está en la calle y quién
está en la calle es la izquierda en un
tema tanto de agenda para la izquierda
en el que previsiblemente se debería de
mover fácilmente Enrique porque la
izquierda no sabe capitalizar el
descontento de esta crisis bueno en
general entre movimientos sociales y
beneficio político nunca hay una nunca
una correlación directa en primer lugar
esto luego la izquierda seguramente un
par de paga un poco sus divisiones
internas que aunque desde hace un año no
hizo una coalición de todos los partidos
que esto resolvió divisiones históricas
Es verdad que aunque haya estado
selecciono la llamada nubes hay
tensiones internas y luego Es verdad que
el hecho de que no hay un liderazgo
claro No porque me son que es un poco el
líder hace un año pero que ha dado Un
paso atrás y ha hecho Que de momento
tampoco no hay ningún líder la ausencia
del líder también en la izquierda
también hace un poco de dificultad un
poco que pueda capitalizar el movimiento
y luego también En tercer lugar yo creo
que la estrategia de que ha aplicado a
la izquierda sobre todo la Francia en
sumisa que es como la parte más parte
más radical pero también al mismo tiempo
la más importante en este espacio ha
sido un poco de entrar como representar
el movimiento y vale el movimiento de
las instituciones una estrategia a veces
radical franceses Es cierto que esta
estrategia tampoco no termina de
funcionar que en parte Quizás lo que les
ha faltado también es intentar
representar una alternativa decir qué
modelo de pensiones queremos lo que
modelo de modelo laboral queremos que
son los debates en Francia estos últimos
meses porque se les puede ahora mismo
retratar con el inmovilismo a la
izquierda
por qué no capitalizo tanto la izquierda
en esta lucha primero porque no fue una
lucha política en la asamblea nacional
Es verdad que la estrategia de la
Francia insumisa fue muy innodible no se
podía Escuchar luego en el senado
minoritarios no se pudieron escuchar en
la calle no fue una lucha política fue
una lucha de los sindicatos quienes
escuchamos siempre los hombres
líderes del sindicalismo Entonces pues
no pudieron capitalizar tanto porque
creo que no fue una lucha política
para solucionar esta crisis después de
verano valdría bastaría con un relevo de
la primera ministra y de cambios en el
gobierno yo creo que puede ayudar a
apaciguar o sea incluso born la primera
ministra lo dijo Yo soy solo un fusible
estoy aquí para hacer reformas para
derecha o izquierda es decir mucho se ha
hablado de un posible relevo en la
figura del actual ministro del interior
gerald dalmarán en ese caso macron
estaría haciendo una Clara puesta
mirando lo que es el valor orden no
nuestra hermana ya ya ha mostrado que
tiene la capacidad de poder tener este
puesto pero sería tirar más hacia la
derecha con reformas aún más
fuerte
arriesgada porque es cierto que Emmanuel
macron su electorado bueno que es una de
las peculiaridades del macroismo es que
pasó de tener una base muy importante
del centro izquierda en 2017 y en 2022
ya era un electorado mucho más
derechizado y envejecido pero a pesar de
eso aún conservaba una parte de Centro
centro izquierda donde alguien como
armarán no no les gustaría luego Es
verdad que el hecho de mirar hacia la
hermana no mirar hacia la incluso elegir
a alguien de los republicanos que es lo
que le piden los la posición de los
derechos de la derecha republicana la
asamblea nacional que es la cuarta
fuerza pero al mismo tiempo es clave
para para que el macroismo tenga la
mayoría absoluta le piden a alguien de
su partido el hecho de decantarse
claramente a la derecha al menos tendría
la ventaja de que le daría quizás una
mayor coherencia ideológica mayor
ideológica en lugar de esta ambigüedad
que a veces Esta ambigüedad es sinónimo
de debilidad porque uno de los errores
que yo creo que no ha sido clave en esta
reforma de las pensiones pero que ha
contribuido al fuerte malestar ha sido
el querer presentar una reforma como
esta que es claramente de derechas como
una medida de izquierda esa justicia
justicia social lo que hacía que el
discurso era aún más más débil con más
cacofonía en caso de que no sea a través
de un cambio de primera ministra y una
crisis de gobierno la otra posibilidad
sería directamente una coalición con los
republicanos Yo creo que es la idea es
la idea de no puede venir de la mayoría
porque no ganaría los 40 y picos
diputados que le hacen falta para tener
la mayoría absoluta Ahora sí firmar una
coalición con la derecha significaría
cambiar de política hacia lo más
moderado no creo porque los republicanos
más moderados y ya están en el campo de
la mayoría hay dos tres claro Quizás 10
que podrían venir pero no son lo
adolescentes Tendría que ir a la franja
más conservadora Quizás la del senado
como serías galaxé que podría traer con
él también unos cuantos diputados
realmente esto no podría resolver la
crisis social que vivimos por lo tanto
resolvería la crisis política y sí
podrían ir más allá en las políticas
como de inmigración y esas cosas y quién
tendrían los credenciales en caso del
día de mañana el día de mañana que el
futuro ya está aquí para tomar el relevo
del macroismo se habla siempre se ha
hablado y se han puesto encima de la
mesa tres nombres no de arma nand el
ministro de economía y Eduard el ex
Primer Ministro no sé si quieren Añadir
a alguien más estos tres nombres como
los valoran de hermanant Philip
son los tres nombres que suenan más
según los sondeos de largo El que tiene
más fuerza
que hay muchos rumores en Francia de que
las relaciones entre macron y philippe
no son buenas aunque no soportaba que su
Primer Ministro tuviera más popularidad
que él siempre se ha dicho eso y ahí
siempre un montón de artículos de prensa
luego yo creo que hay que cogerlo con
pinzas porque luego es cierto un
personaje muy muy importante dentro del
macronismo que es el secretario general
de la Eliseo alexi tiene muy buenas
relaciones que no Philip Pues en
principio el nombre más fuerte es este
luego Es verdad que las relaciones no
son buenas y que Edward creó su propio
partido que se llama Horizon Y eso
tampoco no gustó dentro de cronismo En
definitiva Es probable que haya
tensiones y yo incluso no descartaría de
que puedan emerger nuevos nombres
también en función de que pueda ser el
próximo Primer Ministro se atreverían a
dar alguno que no esté en las quinielas
en estos que estamos dermanal feliz
siempre se habla de ellos pero no sé si
lo que ha salido esta semana en prensa
pero que también hay que
que es el Antiguo ministro de
agricultura que dejó su gobierno por
motivos personales pero que es
considerado un poco como el shushu como
uno de los mimados de macron que había
trabajado con macron cuando estaba en el
Ministerio de economía no aparecen
ninguna mujer vaya ni qué raro eh Mi
nombre es de la izquierda
la presidenta de la asamblea nacional
que que es muy independiente adentro del
macroismo De hecho no se lleva muy bien
con el presidente
johnst text también se ha puesto por él
en algún momento en verdad en la
política nunca se cierran puertas nunca
y menos cuando estamos en la en el poder
en verdad
La Verdadera pregunta es va a haber un
sucesor amac o va a haber varios porque
puede haber varios Edward es muy
independiente dentro de su mayoría
que también está encima de la mesa pero
las extremas van a aumentar y lo que
encontraremos sean nuevos yo creo que
Edward tiene todas las de ganar también
pues estaremos aquí para contarlo
muchísimas gracias a los tres me quedo
sin tiempo para más ha sido un placer
tenerles hoy con nosotros Matías Sandra
Enric y a todos ustedes hasta la próxima
semana quien en Primera Plana gracias